à 24 ans stanley réside à la cité
universitaire sa vie ce sont ses études
le jeune homme apprend en alternance la
gestion des entreprises et des
organisations
mais son histoire est bien plus
chaotique que celle de ses camarades il
y a dix ans stanley était chez lui avec
sa mère et ses frères et soeurs lorsque
la maison s'est effondrée sur eux
tiennent black out total et je ne suis
qu'en gérant j'ai pris conscience
bon en fait je ne comprenais pas ce
qu'il faisait bien pourquoi il fait j'ai
essayé de bouger
il est même ici poussé pour moi en fait
j'avais tellement d'idées comme souvent
que c'était même pas la peine d'essayer
tout ça c'était pour la donc du coup
alors on va dire que c'était assez
effrayant quand même parce qu'être sous
les décombres ne pas savoir est ce que
tu es venu ausculter mort ce jour l'un
stanley n'a que 14 ans ses cris alertent
les voisins mais sa jambe écrasée sous
un lourd poids le bloquera sur place
pendant 24 heures autour de lui les voix
de sa mère sa soeur et ses deux neveux
se sont tus je savais que ma maman était
avec moi et tout mais en fait d'un math
et du médical si tant est qu'elle est
sortie de la maison à temps même si je
savais que ma tête il était décédé trois
jours plus tard l'adolescent se réveille
sur un lit d'hôpital il est en
martinique
il a failli mourir pendant
l'intervention sa jambe droite est
amputé avons mangé ali javey plumage en
gt avec l'unc saint paul et marc ces
réactions c'était un rire et je continue
à avaler la tdg pas et diwan toute façon
il y avait des accès à l'espace et par
vaux traumatise je pense que ça n'a pas
trop effet sur moi et heureusement parce
que j'ai pu partir en larmes parce que
mon père d'une jeune s'est passé quelque
chose mais après ça prend beaucoup de
place compatriote d'une famille
d'accueil à l'autre
l'adolescent s'est reconstruit une vie
autour du handisport l'apprentissage du
français
sa réussite à l'école dix ans après son
arrivée en martinique c'est un jeune
homme indépendant qui rêvent par dessus
tout d'aller jusqu'au master et gagner
enfin un vrai salaire tout le monde me
bats pour survivre
dans le basique gens m'ont jugé voici
tout résister 3 pendant les études et
cetera et cetera
il me dit faire ça je peux faire que ça
je suis pas français je dois continuer
mes études pour voir mes diplômes pour
me débrouiller après avant mon
appartement je parle c'est là à faire
comme beaucoup de jeunes ce soit ou même
attendre que l'eau par an mais que la
cure dans leur bouche voilà
cette année un rêve secret
pouvoir enregistrer un jour les morceaux
qui composent sur sa guitare
[Musique]
l'an prochain si tout va bien il
obtiendra sa nationalité française après
quatre années de titre de séjour
le jeune homme qui admire la résilience
du peuple haïtien peine à comprendre le
matérialisme du monde
à l'heure où les forêts brûlent et ont
toute la jeunesse se cherche un avenir
[Musique]